[Música]
levanten la mano quienes los que están
sentados acá alguna vez consumieron o
les gusta comer ensalada
oa un montón y ahora levanten la mano a
quienes le gusta que esa ensalada venga
condimentada con aceite con vinagre con
hache tos con orégano bien un montón y
por último levanten la mano a quienes le
gusta que esa ensalada venga
condimentada con agrotóxicos
ninguno levantó la mano
y me pregunto si no levantaron la mano
porque saben lo que son los agrotóxicos
porque si conocen que daños generan los
agrotóxicos
porque si no saben nada de ellos pero
les sonó una palabra fea
en realidad no sé qué saben ustedes
sobre agrotóxicos entonces yo ahora les
voy a contar lo que conozco sobre el
tema
los agrotóxicos son sustancias químicas
elaboradas en laboratorios que se
utilizan en producciones agrícolas en
plantaciones de verdura en plantaciones
de fruta en sembrados de soja de trigo y
de otros cereales
y que tienen como finalidad los
agrotóxicos generar cultivos de buena
calidad
a ver buena calidad entre comillas
lo que buscan los agrotóxicos
generar una gran producción y que esa
gran producción que cosechen sea linda a
la vista para luego comercializarla
pero ahora bien
los agrotóxicos generan un triple
impacto negativo
generan un primer impacto negativo en
los productores que manipulan esos
agrotóxicos y que los ponen en esos
alimentos que después nos van a brindar
a nosotros
genera un segundo impacto negativo en el
medio ambiente por ejemplo al aplicar
los agrotóxicos sobre la tierra con el
paso del tiempo éstos comienzan a
descender comienzan a drenar por las
distintas capas hasta llegar a la napa
es el lugar en donde transcurren las
aguas y culmina intoxicando y
envenenando esas aguas que hoy estamos
utilizando y que vamos a seguir
necesitando
y genera un tercer impacto negativo en
nosotros los consumidores que a lo largo
de nuestra vida vamos ingiriendo en
pequeñas dosis agrotóxicos en esas
ensaladas que consumimos todos los días
y entonces ahí es cuando yo me pregunto
si los agrotóxicos tanto daño generan
como puede ser que hoy en día se sigan
utilizándose y consumiendo sé como si
nada pasara
y la respuesta que encontré a esto es
que los agrotóxicos son invisibles están
ahí pero no los vemos
se nos vuelven invisibles a nosotros los
consumidores que todos los días vamos a
la verdulería en búsqueda de frutas y de
verduras y no conocemos cuáles será el
origen de esos alimentos no sabemos cómo
fueron producidos no conocemos qué
sustancias se le echaron para que hoy
estén en estas condiciones en la
verdulería
están ahí pero no los vemos desde que
nos levantamos y buscamos la hierba para
preparar unos mates y desayunar y están
ahí cuando volvemos a casa cansados a la
noche y buscamos realizar un alimento
nutritivo para la familia una ensalada
de hojas verdes están ahí pero no los
vemos
y también los agrotóxicos se vuelven
invisibles para muchos productores
que no tienen conciencia del daño que se
están generando a ellos mismos al
utilizarlo
y para hacerlo un poco más real les voy
a contar aquí traje dos lechugas
tenemos la lechuga número 1 miren la
lechuga grande bonita con una hoja
turgente
esta buena no
y aquí tenemos una lechuga número 2 más
pequeña que tiene marquitas si ustedes
tuvieran que elegir una en la verdulería
para llevar a casa y comer cuál elegiría
la lechuga número uno o la lechuga
número 2
la mayoría dijo la 1
bueno veamos entonces les voy a contar
qué proceso tuvo esta lechuga antes de
llegar a la verdulería que fue donde la
compré vamos a hacer de cuenta que aquí
tengo un combo de agrotóxicos tengo
insecticidas tengo plaguicidas y lo voy
a pulverizar sobre esta lechuga
[Música]
qué función tiene este agrotóxico es
matar a distintas plagas distintos
insectos que vienen a alimentarse de
esta lechuga y qué pasa se alimentan de
ella y le hacen agujeritos le hacen
marquitas no dejan que se desarrolle y
que crezca que es la buena calidad que
busca el agrotóxicos
en definitiva a estos insectos se vienen
a alimentar de esta lechuga como
nosotros también nos alimentamos de ella
y me pongo a pensar que si este
agrotóxico está generado para matar esta
forma de vida que es un insecto
quien nos hizo creer que a nosotros como
otras formas de vida seres humanos no
nos va a generar un daño
bueno y de paso ya que estamos vamos a
poner fertilizante acá y vamos a rociar
esta lechuga
que quiero que esta lechuga se
desarrolle que crezca que sea perfecta
para la vista del que la va a comprar
y ahora vamos a ver esta lechuga la
número 2
la que no eligieron
esta lechuga 2 es una lechuga que fue
producida de manera agroecológica
y producir de manera agroecológica
significa que todo en todo el proceso
productivo
no se han utilizado agrotóxicos
es una lechuga que es más pequeña que no
se desarrollo artificialmente que tiene
agujeros porque vinieron insectos y se
alimentaron de ellas pero es natural
es una lechuga 100% natural
y entonces ahora les voy a volver a
hacer la pregunta ya que conocen el
proceso productivo de ambas lechugas una
perfecta a la vista de todos
y otra pequeña
con marquitas
pero 100% saludable y con mucho sabor
cual lechuga elegirían la lechuga número
1 o la lechuga número 2
la 2 perfecto ahora que conocen el
proceso productivo de cada una de las
lechugas pueden elegir
y descuento las industrias llaman a los
agrotóxicos fitosanitarios guau qué bien
suena no pitó sanitarios sanitarios
suena que a salud a sanidad
ojo no sea cosa que nos vayamos a dar
cuenta que los agrotóxicos generan daño
y nunca se pusieron a preguntar en el
gusto y en los sabores de las frutas y
desde las verduras que hoy tienen lo que
tenían antes hace tiempo atrás
a mi pensar en esto rápidamente me
remonta a mi niñez cuando mis padres me
llevaban de vacaciones a general
belgrano
y con los amigos del barrio a la tarde
con un calor increíble salíamos y
buscábamos aquella casa de algún vecino
que tenía frutales
entrábamos y agarramos los ciruelos
salíamos corriendo con una adrenalina a
la voz de algunos de los chicos que
gritaban corran viene el dueño de casa
y nos sentábamos en ronda a comer esa
ciruela y esa ciruela caliente en pleno
verano que nos chorreaba la boca de jugo
pero tenía un sabor a ciruela
un gusto a ciruela que hoy no lo
encuentro
y ni hablar de las mesas de fin de año
cuando mi tía preparaba los tomates
rellenos y si tomate relleno bien
carnoso con mucho jugo con gusto a
tomate
y de postre
de postre venía la ensalada de fruta de
la abuela
millones de frutas todas cortadas
milimétricamente iguales
le ponía jugo de naranja
y para estirar el jugo la cortaba con
sola
porque no quería que los nietos nos
enojemos y que todos recibamos una
compostera con jugo y así todo
qué sabor que tenía esa fruta aún hoy
puedo recordar ese sabor
y lo que pasó en mí
es que cuando empecé a conocer lo que
los agrotóxicos generaban
empecé a leer y a informarme
no quise ser cómplice entonces modifique
mi manera de producir empecé a producir
de manera agroecológica
empecé a producir sin usar agrotóxicos
de una manera 100 saludable
y hoy ustedes también pueden producir
parte de sus alimentos en casa en un
patio en el balcón en una terraza con
una maceta
alimentos libres de agrotóxicos
y también pueden elegir ir a comprar a
mercados saludables donde le ofrezcan
alimentos como esté
directos de la mano del productor
y lo que sucedió es que en mí todo
cambió
porque los agrotóxicos dejaron de ser
invisibles para mí
y me di cuenta
que lo importante en los alimentos está
en el interior
y no lo que aparentan
y eso es un poco como la vida misma
lo que importa de las personas es su
interior de su corazón son sus emociones
son sus sentimientos y no el aspecto
físico
y hoy
para todos ustedes
los agrotóxicos también dejaron de ser
invisibles
y a partir de ahora
van a poder elegir y exigir alimentos
por lo que son realmente y no por lo que
aparentan ser muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]